ahora soy de honor de khan academy en
este vídeo repasaremos el contenido que
ofrecemos a maestros y alumnos y qué es
lo que lo hace único primero a nuestros
cursos puedes ver todos nuestros cursos
haciendo clic en el menú desplegable en
la parte superior izquierda de la página
web de khan academy
tenemos artículos vídeos y ejercicios
para cursos de matemáticas organizados
por cursos desde lo más básico cómo
aprender a sumar hasta álgebra lineal y
también nos organizamos por año en
algunos países desde 1º de primaria
hasta secundaria y bachillerato además
de matemáticas tenemos cursos completos
de ciencias economía y computación
incluyendo programación interactiva y
cursos de animación por computadora
creados en colaboración con pixar y
constantemente estamos agregando
contenido nuevo
selecciona una de tus clases de khan
academy la pestaña contenido te mostrará
el enlace y la secuencia del curso que
seleccionaste la mayoría de nuestros
cursos están divididos en unidades y en
cada unidad hay varias lecciones estas
lecciones incluyen recursos informativos
y prácticos como vídeos artículos y
ejercicios en muchos de los cursos las
pruebas combinan los ejercicios de
varias lecciones la unidad termina con
un examen que califica el entendimiento
de toda la unidad
nuestro contenido es confiable está
creado por un equipo de maestros y
expertos en la materia colaboramos con
organizaciones educativas líderes para
asegurarnos de que nuestro contenido
está actualizado y refleja tu programa
curricular nuestro contenido es
interactivo tenemos preguntas que le
piden a los alumnos que lean e
interpreten mapas imágenes y pasajes de
textos tenemos gráficas interactivas y
gráficas para enseñarles a los alumnos a
leer e interpretar datos con una gran
variedad de preguntas te invitamos a que
exploren nuestro contenido para que
puedas ver toda la variedad de
ejercicios y preguntas que ofrecen
ofrecemos retroalimentación inmediata al
responder una pregunta los alumnos
sabrán si su respuesta es correcta
casi incorrecta
o equivocada ofreceremos apoyo a los
alumnos que tengan dificultad con un
problema tales como vídeos y artículos
relacionados pistas con estrategias de
solución y argumentos que explican por
qué cierta respuesta es correcta o
equivocada y por último nuestro
contenido es accesible amigable y
promueve una mentalidad de crecimiento
para que los alumnos sepan que pueden
aprender lo que sea queremos que los
alumnos sientan que reciben una tutoría
personal modelamos los procesos de
pensamiento para que los usen para hacer
preguntas y resolver problemas para más
información visita khan academy punto o
hereje diagonal visuales